alcohol is holding you back everybody is
searching for Optimal Health Peak
Performance the more productivity in
their work how to lose weight and yet
they're not realizing that this vision
of what alcohol-free could feel like
that is the one thing that will give
them what they are looking for rwer Fabs
is a former oil broker who after a
falling out with booze decided to put
the plug in The Jug the benefits were so
profound he would later walk away from
his career and finance to become an
alcohol-free lifestyle Advocate our
relationship with alcohol is
intrinsically linked to the experiences
we had as a child that's just a fact
ruri co-founded oneyear no beer a
subscription-based alcohol prevention
program that now boasts over 100,000
members if you want to change your
behavior get around a community of
people who are living like that as we
welcome this new year I offer this
conversation as encouragement to
consider the many ways in which alcohol
continues to interfere with your health
because it's time to put booze in the
rear
view I'm extremely proud to introduce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com Rory so nice to meet you thank
you for doing this uh what you have to
share what you represent uh what you've
created what you advocate for I think is
not only extremely powerful but also
extremely timely as we see mainstream
culture start to catch up with what
you've been kind of talking about for
quite some time now there is there is a
definite surge in popularity uh and
enthusiasm for the alcohol-free
lifestyle that is not only a an
affirmation of your work but on some
level might even be surprising the
extent to which it it seems to be taking
hold yeah well rich thank you so much
for having me on the podcast and um you
know I think like you just said this has
been nearly a decade now um nine and a
bit years of um spreading this message
and when we first started um spreading
this message we were definitely early
right we were we were early but at the
time I was thinking oh this is this is
this is going to happen now and people
were saying oh this is so in the moment
like what you just said people were
saying that 9 years ago and I think what
I've realized is that Paradigm shifts
like this like major Paradigm shifts
where Society is completely saturated in
alcohol and the world is changing its
relationship with alcohol happen really
really slowly right and um you know
we'll talk talk more about this but that
kind of kind of changed how I operated
in the business because instead of being
focused on right here and right now like
what's happening in the next few months
or the next year it became no this
paradigm shift is going to happen over
decades like you just have to sit in and
keep spreading the message and keep
coming on Amazing podcasts like this and
inspiring people and helping them think
about things slightly differently and I
think what's been amazing is to see all
of these sober influences come out these
alcohol free drinks businesses I mean I
can think of probably four or five
alcohol uh free businesses that came
from one year no that we know of right
wow um so we have been one of the
pioneers and early adopters helping make
this paradigm shift in the world and now
the momentum is growing and the momentum
is growing and the momentum is growing
it's exciting the podcast that Andrew
huberman did last year on alcohol I
think was the number
one podcast or number two pod most
listened to podcast on the Apple podcast
platform across the world for the entire
year wow I don't know if you knew that I
didn't know it but I mean the hubman
podcast is our source of good science
that we use to um influence the program
and there are so many elements of that
that we've adopted into our programs and
I think not only is that really telling
but I would say
I know most of the people in my industry
we're all friends right we we we chat to
each other I'm not seeing them on the
big podcasts out there I'm not seeing
them being interviewed on TV on radio
I'm not seeing them yet and I think this
is the next Evolution like you are an
early adopter you had Andy on early
you're now having me on to spread this
conversation this would be my sort of my
Call to Arms if you like to any other
podcast or influencer to say let's
really get this message out out there
there are so many of us who are
spreading this message and that message
being do you know what alcohol is
holding you back and that's it it's
simple right if you are regularly
consuming alcohol it is holding you back
even if you're only very periodically
consuming it it's holding you back there
is no positive physiological
benefit whatsoever yeah that comes from
drinking
period yeah and and let let's talk about
that specifically right we don't you
know a lot of people don't want to hear
that message you know oh this my
trainers give me cancer right you know
everything's all the health issue but
the the facts are absolutely there it's
100% poison it's neurotoxic it's
terrible for our brains it's terrible
for our bodies there are no
physiological benefits at all whatsoever
to drinking alcohol um it was so
impactful I saw yesterday in the news
that Lewis Hamilton is has said he's
just done done 4 months alcohol free and
he did it because he's looking for an
extra 1% this year right or coming into
next year so you know this is the this
is really the message is about everybody
is searching for Optimal Health people
are looking for Peak Performance they're
looking for more productivity in their
work they're looking for how to lose
weight they're trying to get all these
things and yet they're not realizing
that this thing this daily habit that
they're doing that the whole of society
is normal izing that is the one thing
that will give them what they are
looking
for the Counterpoint to that would be
the person who says I understand
everything that you're saying but when I
need to take the edge off or I want to
take the edge off a drink is pretty
reliable in doing that completely and as
an antidote to the loneliness epidemic
if I want to be social and see my
friends uh that is you know something
that's sort of doer like we go to the
bar we go to the pub this is how I get
to hang out with the people that I care
about and so you're asking me to
sacrifice that when I'm already lonely
coming out of a pandemic and and
deprived of the social interaction
required to just be a healthy human
completely and that is what the person
who drinks alcohol would say are the
benefits okay that's the benefits of
drinking social inclusion uh the
benefits of drinking are being being
included on in all those things and
being able to do that stuff and being
able to take the edge off and so as long
as there are benefits to drinking
alcohol people are going to continue
seeking it and looking for it and I
think this is part of the conversation
that we're going to have today which is
that if the only option for people is
abstinence right or drinking
problematically or drinking like fish
like everybody does then we're not
helping people in that Middle Lane area
we're not helping people in that area
where they have a better relationship
I'm not going to call it a healthy
relationship because there is no healthy
relationship but where they have a
better relationship with alcohol and
that means that they can still do some
of those social things they can still
operate how they were but it's not
having that significant impact that
significant negative impact on their
life what do we know and not know in
terms of what alcohol is doing to our
body to our sleep to our mental health
Etc
yeah um well like you said I mean the
hubman podcast was was fantastic and I
think um when if you look Dr Arman is a
perfect example he um doc Arman he says
you know every time you take a drink
right so just two units it starts to
dull your prefrontal cortex which is
that melon behind your brain that's that
area of rational decision-making uh
moral compass comes from there so he
says how often do you want rational
decision- making and moral compass to go
on holiday and that's effectively what
happens when you drink and you know now
we're talking about not just doc Arman
Andrew hubman talking about it being
entirely neurotoxic to the brain it
shrinks the brain over time causes
memory loss like
so what we what we can just draw a line
under is say that this is completely
toxic there are there are no benefits to
drinking alcohol um it's going to have a
significantly negative impact on your
brain a significantly negative impct on
your body and yet the thing about that
is is it's so prevalent in society it's
so
normalized that the conversation of you
have to be abstinent I think is the
conversation which is stopping many many
many people from taking just the first
one or two steps to change things like
sleep as an example alcohol is
horrendous for sleep right alcohol stops
US going into deep sleep deep sleep is
that area that that that needed part of
sleep where actually the vast majority
what they believe now the vast majority
of neuroplasticity happens okay so
that's our brain's ability to learn and
learn new things and change Behavior so
drinking alcohol is in direct negative
correlation to trying to change Behavior
it stops you changing behavior and
there's so many areas like this where it
it holds her back let's talk about
weight loss right alcohol significantly
inhibits your weight loss um it's 100%
poison therefore the liver must process
that before it processes other um fat
loss so it stops you losing weight plus
there's lots of calories in let's let's
take a little example here okay imagine
I created a pill right that would help
you for your headache and you have a
headache and you go down to the pharmacy
and you get the pill and it's wonderful
this this this it acts incredibly fast
it removes your headache you feel so
much more at ease and then 15 minutes
later you need to take another pill and
then so you feel a bit better again and
that's all very good then another 15
minutes go by and guess what now you
need to take two pills okay and this
goes on for the evening to try and get
rid of your headache and then you go to
bed that night and you fall asleep and
you wake up the next day and the
headache is 10 times worse you feel low
and you feel in more pain than you did
before how successful would that be like
as a product yeah not great right so and
this unless you're the person selling
the product then it's pretty great yeah
that's another conversation to be had
and this is the thing with alcohol is it
must be one of the world's worst
relievers of stress I recently
interviewed a wonderful woman Dr reget
Sin from Yale University and she spent
the last 30 years studying alcohol and
addiction and they asked her to set up a
new Department specifically for alcohol
abuse abuse studies and she got 6 months
into this setup um of the of the
department and she went back to the
board and said I don't want to call it
Yale University study for alcohol abuse
I want to call it Yale's University
study for stress because alcohol is just
the outcome the actual source is the
stress and the stress that we have and
so alcohol is a terrible terrible stress
reliever for people and I think inside
all of this is what is keeping this
completely stuck together like knowing
that it's so bad for our health bad for
our mental health it's you know as
Professor David nut proved and got
kicked out of the UK government for
proving that alcohol is the world's most
harmful drug and significantly negative
on our physical and mental health why is
it so prevalent and that is this part
that we are trying to challenge it is
the social conditioning it is $2
trillion dollars of marketing it is an
entire machine which has spent decades
upon decades upon Decades of programming
us to believe that this thing this
substance is the source of our health is
the source of fun happiness of every of
success of everything and interestingly
right you look at the the the
advertising budget for for alcohol right
and the alcohol industry in the UK since
2004 200 before was Peak booze in the UK
okay the most amount we were drinking
and the advertising budget spent in the
UK pretty much follows that trend line
right the restrictions started to come
in place and all of those things so all
of this advertising all of this machine
has been making us believe that alcohol
is this Source um there was a another
study recently I think this was probably
three four years ago and there was an
audience with a journalist in hiding in
and there was some people trying to put
a study together to study whether
alcohol was good for you or not right
and so they wanted to prove they were on
stage saying we want to prove that
moderate drinking is good for you okay
and the journalist called this out I
think it was in the New York Times
because the room was full of the AL
alcohol industry sure yeah so this is
all the misinformation all that stuff
out there that has been programming us
to believe that it is a source well it's
so prevalent to your point and we're so
indoctrinated into a culture where we
don't even second guess the fact that
it's readily available and has been
positioned to be this elixir of good
times and and you know something that is
considered innocuous in comparison to
the drugs that are illegal when in fact
the facts tell a very different story um
yet I do think we're seeing this this up
swing or upturn in especially in younger
people who are opting out of this
Paradigm which I think is really cool
and I came across a study and
researching you know to speak to you
today this Sterling University study
from 2017 that showed that 93% of people
had a drink when they didn't want to and
84% had experienced pressure from
friends to drink alcohol so we have on
the one hand the science the irrefutable
set of facts that show a really negative
picture in terms of what this drug is
doing to us on the other hand the more
nefarious foe in this equation really is
our social structure that keeps people
stuck in Behavior patterns that don't
serve them for fear of being ostracized
by you know their their ingroup or their
community of people yes and that's
adequate enough strong enough to keep
people doing things they don't want to
do because the fear of suddenly not
being able to participate in that is
more than adequate to you know
perpetuate a negative habit completely
and you know that was our study with
Sterling university did you commission
that study did we did we we we've done
various studies with Sterling University
over the years um but I think you know
that element of peer pressure like look
at where I came from you know the oil
broking industry um and my boss telling
me that if I took a break from Al was
like I I want to change my relationship
with alcohol I I really think it's
holding me back and he said you are
committing commercial suicide if you
stop drinking and and here I was built
up a very successful business you know
team of guys with me and for however
many years maybe 10 years in this
industry I was very focused on being the
number one oil broker in the world like
that was where I was going and here I
was left with this decision to make of
like do I really say goodbye to all of
that and I I think this is in part what
people are saying they're like okay
that's very well I could see that I
could be healthier I understand that
it's a neurotox I understand that it's
poisonous I like the way it makes me
feel everybody's doing it and I don't
really want to be ostracized from
society if I stop I don't really want to
stop drinking and be the guy who's left
out here's an example of peer pressure
I've been standing with a group of guys
having a drink and um they are all
playing they play cricket together and
they're chatting away and they're
talking about how important this season
is right and one of the guys goes look
why don't we get Mark you know he's the
best player out of all of us and a bunch
of guys are like we just can't do it we
can't do it because he doesn't
drink I mean that is the world we live
in so I think as long as that exists
it's going to to be very challenging for
people to be just completely not
drinking and I think inside this gray
area that we've been trying to say is
there is alternative to just not
drinking right there's actually an area
of of of drinking where you mostly don't
drink and that's something I choose
right I choose personally to drink in
control I rarely have a drink the vast
majority of the time I spend alcohol
free every time I have a drink I feel
absolutely terrible um I might have one
with dinner but it's just rare all of
the associations in my brain that I used
to have like you go for a steak you need
a drink or you go to the rugby you need
to have pints all of those associations
have disappeared so what I really call
this now is like it's it's like having a
base of alcohol-free of knowing and
loving that version of yourself but
occasionally tapping into that world
where it's so expected it's so ingrained
so you can join in with them and then
get yourself back out again it's
interesting that you dip your toe back
in from time to time rather than just
say like with everything that you know
why do you still make the choice
occasionally to to embibe for the two
things that you talked about earlier for
those benefits that are very real and
they are for the vast majority of people
the vast majority of people out there
are not in very severe alcoholism the
vast majority of people are sitting on
the borderline they're sitting somewhere
between um I drink I drink every day a
little bit or I binge drink and the
wheels come off but then I stop drinking
for a bit and they look at this and they
say hang on a minute I don't want to
stop drinking I just want to be able to
drink a bit less um and if we say to
them well you no you can't do that that
there you can't do that you you have to
go and be completely abstinent then
they'll just go okay I'm not going to do
anything and this is what's happening so
the reason why we stumbled on that and I
say stum LED but it cost us a fortune
and years and it was very expensive in
learning it is that when we were sitting
down and talking to our customers and
this is people who came into the
challenge had done the challenge a
little bit and you know been successful
with it in various different ways and we
were talking to them about their
experience and people would say you know
I was watching your ads on Facebook for
two years before I signed up to the
challenge and I'm you know about paid
media marketing that means that cost you
a
fortune and and in it we started to ask
people like what's going on so we had
another survey done we had another piece
of research done and this is now tens of
thousands of people who came through
this piece of research and of those tens
of thousands of people in countries all
over the world 84% do not want to stop
drinking right so if our only rhetoric
is come and stop drinking come and do 90
days or come and do whatever it is is
then we're stopping people helping
change their relationship with alcohol
earlier and this is one of the biggest
changes in what we are doing now because
we talk about control and if you in in
this whole area of prevention if we can
talk about control and say Hey you can
have a healthier relationship with
alcohol and when they come through a
program help them see that the
healthiest relationship with alcohol is
to be predominantly abstinent then we
can help people much much earlier yeah I
understand that intellectually I totally
get it uh yet at the same time like my
brain's lighting up like a Christmas
tree because I'm like a 12-step guy and
I come into this from a very different
set of experiences because I'm the guy
who hears you can drink occasionally and
I think well if I could drink once in a
while and dip my toe in then I should
just drink every day like I'm just wired
differently you know I have a problem
and that problem requires uh a certain
program and set of tools that I have to
diligently practice every single day or
I'm in you know fear or there you know I
create I create a you know a a grave
risk to my health and well-being as a
result that's a very different
individual the classic alcoholic or
addict um sits in a very different set
of circumstances from the people that
you're communicating with who don't have
that problem or are not necessarily uh
dealing with something severe or acute
just you know are sick and tired of
occasionally feeling lousy being hung
over being pressured into drinking when
they don't want to um and I think the
challenge aspect of of what you've
created gives people a a way to test the
reality of what their relationship is
because to the to your point about what
was it 84% said they don't want to quit
drinking you know how many of those
don't want to quit because they have a
problem they don't want to break up with
their best friend versus somebody who's
like this is not problematic for me so I
don't see a reason to have to quit
there's a deep sort of
psychological network of neurons at play
that that lead people to say things that
are not in their best interest totally
totally or or to throw up the wall
against you know making the change that
could actually you know be the
differentiator between the life they're
leading and the life they wish to lead
totally
and and I think this is the again the
widening of the conversation here okay
um Dr Judson Brewer being on this
podcast amazing person he's coming back
soon have him coming back um you're
supposed to Surf with him um he's also
been on our podcast and uh you know
we've had part of his work on our
programs amazing human being but he is
helping people who have who might
traditionally be considered very severe
or s alcoholism or addiction to change
their relationship with that to almost
not drinking or not drinking at all
using just meditation okay and there is
Dr Joe despenza who is getting people to
stand up out of wheelchairs an entire
life in a wheelchair through meditation
another very successful intervention for
um people changing their relationship
with addictions is boxing sport right um
interestingly the most successful by
volume of people right into vention in
the world for helping people go from
alcohol use disorder severe or severe
alcohol use disorder to abstinent or a
better relationship controlled drinking
there is one thing out there in the
world that stands high above everything
else do you know what that thing is
running you would like it to be that
yeah what is it
time explain most people grow out of it
in time
it's the most successful intervention
out there and the thing about this is
okay so we're using words like you're an
alcoholic and this is alcoholism and all
of those things is let's just widen up
this conversation to say that different
people need different things that some
things might work for some people and
might not work for other people and
there is a huge array of tools and
understanding that we can apply into
this subject matter here that might be
able to help someone sure and I think if
we go with that widening of a of a of a
place because like you said there are
some people who say oh well that's not
for me or you know I don't identify with
that um I don't think there's only
there's not one way and that's what's
amazing about you rich right you know
you've brought Andy onto this podcast
this is clearly another way and it's
helping people and you've brought me
onto the podcast this is another way and
it's helping people and there's lots
more of us there's lots more of us that
are skating this line of what would be
could be this or could be that and yet
people are coming out of it and
transforming their lives MH time as an
intervention is an interesting concept I
can't help but wonder whether that's
because everybody has to have their
their experiences to come to the
conclusion that it no longer serves them
and you can't incept that level of
willingness into somebody who's not
receptive to hearing it they have to
have a certain experience or reach a
certain pain threshold before they're
ready to make a change that's
uncomfortable and even if you have a
casual relationship with alcohol it
still is like a very reliable friend
that you're being asked to break up with
or to spend time apart from and if
alcohol isn't directly tied to a series
of you know chaotic uh disruptive events
in your life it's harder to make that
argument until that person kind of
brushes up against something that makes
them reframe that relationship yeah I
think like you said there a lot of
people are waiting for a rock bottom
moment um they're waiting for their hand
to be forced the DUI or um the the the
partner to say that's it I'm leaving and
with all of my soul like deep to my core
I want to help people before that I want
to prevent that I want to
tickle scratch GW at the bits inside
where they can make a decision make a
change make a judgment that connects to
them and makes them realize that alcohol
is the thing if if we swim back Upstream
a bit more into and look at this
prevention piece people are not looking
for not drinking when when they are
they're still stuck in The Matrix
they're loving drinking it's not a
problem they don't have a problem people
convince themselves right right now
we're in dry janary they're like okay I
do dry janary every year therefore I
don't have a problem but I also drink
three bottles of wine every day at lunch
now I know a guy who said that to me
right yeah you know he drinks three
bottles of wine at lunch every day
probably finishes off with all sorts of
whiskey at because he can do dry January
it's not a problem because he has proved
to himself that he can quit put it down
when he wants to uh never mind you know
the the the white knuckling and whatever
all of those things the delusion went
into you know just making it to day 30
so he could continue to perpetuate that
argument as a form of denial but yeah
millions and millions of people Rich
millions and millions why this is why
you know people who come into Alcoholics
Anonymous or or 12ep programs will once
they you know kind of get well or better
will identify as a grateful alcoholic or
addict because the pain was so severe
and the Habit was so pronounced they
were forced to reckon with it and you
know break up with that lover and as a
result have been blessed with tools and
this brand new life that has created
something wonderful out of you know this
this
disease um but for the person who's a
heavy user or Drinker who can continue
along that path without wreaking
inadequate amount of havoc in their life
where they have to confront or or or you
know deal with the fact that they might
have a problem they're stuck in a
cycle that is harder to break because
there aren't circumstances you can point
to to say it's time you got to give it
up yeah and they live their lives you
know most of them lives the rest of
their lives in this suboptimal state
where they're really not living the life
that is freely available to them
otherwise yeah
exactly and I think if we can direct the
conversation to where people are looking
where if if they're not looking to stop
drinking then where are they looking
they want to lose weight they want to
double their business this year um I
mean Lewis Hamilton right he wants an
extra 1% imp performance Improvement um
they want to avoid divorce uh they want
to be a better father be a better mother
they want to be calmer want to be
happier so so if we can direct the
conversation to there and then help
people do the math oh you want to lose
weight do you okay well let me just
explain about what your regular drinking
alcohol it'sit of a trojan horse right
because that person is never going to
walk into an AA meeting never and and if
they really do have a problem by kind of
welcoming the challenge under the rubric
of weight loss or whatever
uh the truth will be revealed as we
talked about earlier either they're not
going to make it or they stuck something
will happen and yeah it will become
clear rather soon whether that that
program needs to be kind of you need
escalated exactly well then that's
another widening part again so it it
doesn't go from oh I tried to do the
challenge and therefore I need to go to
AA what we're saying is okay so you've
tried to do dry January for a year a few
times you've stopped drinking for a
month but then it comes back well there
are drivers of compulsive Behavior do
you know what those are and are you
mitigating those and are you doing
anything about them let me ask you um do
you have a high level of stress in your
life right what do you think every time
I ask somebody that what do you think
they say yeah of course they do well we
just talked about why stress is
absolutely intrinsically linked to your
relationship with alcohol it's the most
well well used known available readily
available tool for dealing with stress
but it also creates stress alcohol
releases significant amounts of cortisol
in fact they recently found regular
alcohol consumption over time increases
the production of cortisol okay so
you're not only releasing cortisol in
the moment but you're producing more
cortisol over time now cortisol sends
you into fight or flight right so your
sympathetic nervous system stressed out
your busy busy busy all day you know
building the business being successful
whatever it is and then not only that
but so so that stress during the day
then gets you to that end of the end of
the day where you're like I need
something to take the edge off but what
people don't realize is that alcohol
consumption over time is reducing your
ability to deal with stress right so I
speak to successful driven business
owners all the time and I say to them do
you have more stress now or have you
reduced your ability ility to deal with
stress and I think that's the thing
people are not realizing about it let's
have a conversation about stress right
and let's deal with the stress let's
talk about sleep let's talk about these
other things because that's what you are
looking for and in the background just
like you said we're going to help you
change your relationship with
[Music]
alcohol every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to per performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra right on the trails and I just got
the new NextGen Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but an also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none second
skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra tea and the ultra shorts which
have this pocket right at the base of
the spine that perfectly anchors your
phone no jiggle I'm just so proud to
partner with an and I love their vision
for the future where their gear is
engineered for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com when we cast our Gaze on the
emotional landscape even more broadly uh
the other thing that comes up for me is
the difference between abstinence and
emotional sobriety if you really are an
alcoholic and you find your way into
12ep there is the initial phase of
detoxifying your body right uh and and
perhaps the Trojan Horse there is people
come in they're just like I just want to
learn how to stop drinking um what they
don't realize and what comes later is
this notion that that putting the bottle
down is really just the beginning of
trying to figure out a way to be
emotionally sober because when you no
longer have that coping mechanism all of
the uncomfortable emotions flare up and
you're and you're and you're left with
no tools for how to manage them because
the way that you have done it
historically has been taken away so in
the case of the people that you have
worked with given that you know perhaps
they're not alcoholics on some level
everybody is self-medicating with
alcohol and so when you remove their
favorite medication what is replaced
there and and what is the work that
needs to be done to identify whatever
those triggers are and find healthier
ways of processing and transcending the
emotional uh kind of
um uh what's the word I want to use the
emotional uh impulses and and and
patterns that emerge that require
redress because without any kind of
tools to redress them they're going to
wreak havoc and so perhaps you know you
know alcohol resulted in angry
flareups but if there's a latent anger
underneath that you've been medicating
with alcohol to kind of keep under wraps
suddenly that's going to come out and
it's probably going to be worse than it
was when you were drinking yeah yeah and
I think this part
was the bit I felt you know really
needed to evolve because I could see
that we were helping people to take a
break from alcohol I could see that we
would we would give them this insight
and this vision of what alcohol-free
could feel like and you know what
happens when somebody has been regularly
drinking and stops they get all of this
positive feeling that you know all these
things come back but we weren't really
there to help them with this emotional
issue or the big t- word right right
trauma um the driver of so much of our
behavior um and so this is why we needed
to evolve into more intensive program
for people so that we could start
looking at those underlying things
because you're right right let's look at
the work by gabber mate who
significantly influences the programs in
here or Bess of vandero right uh the
body keeps the score our relationship
with alcohol is intrinsically linked to
the experiences we had as a child that's
just a fact right now if we called this
hey come and sort out your trauma
program sure I think it would be even
less successful than hey come and sort
out your drinking problem right that's
the so we have to do that in the
background um now we use wonderful tools
like oh you had Dick Schwartz on the on
the things we use ifs we use um uh
sematic experiencing things like that to
help people start to feel these emotions
but more importantly to link them back
to these past experiences that they were
that are running on
autopilot let me give you a little
example so you know Decades of therapy I
did Psychotherapy psychodynamic therapy
of talk therapy since six years old
right tons and tons of counseling and
therapy and I wouldn't say I said it
helped evolve me significantly but I
never really got to I never really came
to find my
trauma and when I went through a
meditation but also in time with that
with some trumatic experiencing I
released some stuff and discovered a
very old memory that nobody had talked
about my mom and dad didn't talk about
it my siblings nobody really talked
about it and it was when I was 2 years
old okay and I fell off the boat now
when I fell off the boat my dad was down
in the cuddi and he had to come up and
he literally had to dive down and swim
down and save me right now that created
this imprint in my brain of needing to
be saved I had no idea about this until
you know like Steve Jobs says you have
no idea until you look back and connect
all the dots so what did it mean for me
well through my life I had all these
near-death experiences including my
suicide attempts almost done every
single one of those things I always had
somebody nearby there to save me when I
looked for partners I was looking for
somebody who had saved me I was so
destructive so disruptive I was looking
for somebody to come and save me when I
built my businesses they were always in
suffering and I was looking for you know
the next freelancer or agency or Guru to
come and save my business so this
pattern was locked in my subconscious I
didn't even know it existed and this is
the power of trauma and so when I got to
understand that and shift it I got
awareness of it that's the most
empowerful thing about doing the work
right I know you're such a big advocate
of doing the work and this is it is when
once I got awareness I could say hang on
a minute I'm running that patent again
like I I don't need somebody to save me
I I don't need somebody to come and save
me well the other piece there of course
and sorry I don't mean to jump in um but
the other piece isn't just needing
somebody to save you it's putting
yourself in Peril so that you can be
saved so you're you're actually
incurring risk into your life
unconsciously for the purpose of
whatever the emotional experience of
being saved does for you exactly and
that was the pattern of my life like
ADHD severely
destructive um all of those behaviors so
I mean I I that's why I could easily
have such addictive behavior and you
know fit alcohol like a glove coming
into that but now I'm such a huge
advocate of doing the work like let's
put it as simple as
this alcohol is showing up a bit too
prevalent in your life okay let's change
that but first of all let's change that
by doing the work you're such a huge fan
of doing the work right that's what this
podcast is all about it's about showing
people what they need to do and the
things they can do to do the work and I
think when you do the work that is what
is going to change your relationship
with alcohol but people don't want to do
the work but they're up for the
challenge you know they're like 28 days
if their mates are going to do it I'll
do it too we'll see I'll beat you like
that sounds fun right and there's an end
point on that um so that's a much easier
thing to get you know people to
subscribe to it is it is the you've got
to start nice you mean the work like I'm
just going to you know say no to the
beer at the pub but you know that's how
these things have to begin and I think
what you've done really effectively is
just create a welcome that where um hey
it's it's nice and warm in here it's
cozy come on in there's lots of other
people doing it we're having a good time
we're building Community around it
that's the other huge piece of course um
where you feel supported and you don't
feel alone or like some kind of uh
insane outlier in trying to do this yeah
the community element is is huge um it's
so so powerful interestingly you know we
were talking about dry janary and things
like that um and what a lot of people
when when they do dry janary is they
hide away right they stay at home they
go to the gym they change up their
routine and what they're doing with all
of this avoid their Social Circle cancel
all that stuff count down the days to
the 1st of February so we can go out and
get smashed again and what we're doing
while doing that is we are reiterating
this belief right this this whole social
conditioning that we need alcohol to
have a good time that we need alcohol to
have a fun life like Jan is so boring
cold Dart that's what I'm not drink
right so and and I think that's what can
actually create more of an issue with
with people's relationship with alcohol
the main thing there is what's happening
is people are becoming more
disconnected right now unless you're a
sociopath we don't want to be
disconnected right we want to be
connected and so this is the importance
of being sociable being around people
building a community for yourself who
are changing their relationship with
alcohol it's so well ingrained right
that that if you want to change your
behavior get around a community of
people who are living like that and I
think 9 10 years ago when I started
changing my relationship with alcohol um
that Community was pretty small nowadays
it's huge right so don't don't hide away
during dry Jan let's get out there go
also the whole point is to develop some
level of resilience and if you're just
isolating and hiding from people then
you're just preventing yourself from
having those slightly challenging
experiences that if you weather through
them will teach you that you can do this
thing right and it it emboldens you and
and it and it strengthens that reflex to
say no instead of you know sort of
catering to social preference yeah well
let's take it back I want to hear the
whole story like I want to hear how this
all came to be because it's there's some
entertaining [__] in there like about
what happened with you
man there so you grew up on this weird
Island yes right I'd never even heard of
this island M the aisle of M like way up
in the northwest of Scotland you should
run a retreat there yeah oh it's amazing
beautiful you like I like well you live
in myca that sounds like a lot better
like keep it simple I moved from one
Island to another it was m and now it's
Mala yeah right well that makes sense is
there a direct flight between the two
probably not um so kid growing up in M I
don't know what goes on there but I
presume there's quite a bit of drinking
absolutely in fact um west coast of
Scotland um if you were to put it on the
as a country it would be amongst the
highest in Europe uh of drinking culture
alcohol per capita um so yeah very
synonymous with drinking culture up
there um now
um my uh my parents were originally born
in England moved up to the aisle of mul
and um so Des was that what what yeah um
I think my dad married a beautiful woman
and didn't want anybody to Nick her off
so he he bought a he bought a hill farm
which going to squander away with this
woman and okay made sure she could that
sounds healthy she couldn't go very
healthy there's a book about that she's
written one um so that's next for me
well get my get my mom on the podcast
yeah for sure I need to know more about
this island and you being you know
absconded with it's it's it's a
beautiful beautiful part of the world
260 rain days a year though so um but
anyway so I was very challenged in the
head um I think I came out with a bump
and um now been diagnosed with ADHD but
back then and on the aisle of M they had
absolutely no idea what this was they
just didn't know they just knew they
didn't like it um and so at 6 years old
um after being significantly disruptive
through school U my parents were given
an ultimatum drugs or counseling um and
to me I feel fortunate obviously
everyone is different and make their own
choices but I feel very for fortunate
that they chose counseling because it
started from a very young age me trying
to understand what the hell was going on
in here at 9 million miles an hour so
you were just hyperactive sit still
couldn't pay attention couldn't learn
and so all the way through that my
parents were trying to juggle this and
five kids and businesses and all of that
kind of stuff so um it was very
difficult to get attention and I think
quite young I figured out that when you
set stuff on fire you get attention um
so quite disruptive and you know through
that my parents would say you know
you're special you're gifted but the
people out there they were like you're
bad you're naughty you're
disruptive um and I I recently spoke at
um ADHD UK um I'm very very passionate
about ADHD I'm very passionate about the
conversation here about ADHD uh I was
just it just wasn't known there wasn't
support so when I got to 13 years old
and with the noise going on inside my
head and not understanding who I was or
where I belonged um I decided to take an
overdose um and uh I was very very dark
place you know um I think I've talked
about suicide before but I think there's
such a great misunderstanding around it
I think the place somebody gets to when
they want to leave is such a horrendous
place like it's it's it's a horrific
feeling and and and there is no option
and there's no other alternative you
you're the problem you're the issue and
you and the solution is gained by you
departing mhm it's it's not a a a
conscious decision it's awful how old
were you at this point at 13 13 wow 14 I
actually stepped off the stairs with a
taaj jitsu belt around my neck I was
determined to go and my parents were out
at an anniversary dinner very thoughtful
of me and they had an argument and came
home early and they came home as I was
dangling on the stairs and so they
brought me down and coming from that my
dad dad had worked at you know voluntary
at child line and he was an amazing man
and very wise and and very knowledgeable
um and he knew from working with these
kids and also cancer kids and things
like that he'd done a lot of work that
when you give a child hope they're far
more likely to pull out of whatever it
is they're going through so he
encouraged me to write a letter to
somebody famous now my dad was called
Richard uh he run multiple businesses
but one of of them was a recording
studio um and so I was thinking of
somebody famous and I thought ah Richard
Branson so I wrote a letter to Richard
Branson um at 14 and I said amongst a
whole bunch of stuff about the weather
and and how many sheet there were on the
AIS of M I also said and I think this
goes to show how separated my brain was
but from this conversation of being
special and gifted and yet naughty and
bad and the special element I I wrote
into him I said I'm going to change the
world one day and I'm looking forward to
having lunch with you so that's when I
set off to try and change the world so I
left school before the legal age set up
my first company um determined to be the
next Richard Branson um ran that for two
years in fact by the time I was 25 I
tried five different companies um the
biggest of which employed 10 people for
three years we used to run a a call
center a little tell Center in in in
edenburgh um and I was really desperate
to try and make this massive impact in
the world and yet here I was just
failing again and again and again in
fact I called myself a Serial fail
preneur and back one day on the
wonderful Isle of Mal drinking my
sorrows um sitting in the pub I was
speaking to a friend there and he said
that's interesting story rui he said um
you know you should go on that TV
program where all failed entrepreneurs
go and I was like what's that didn't
really watch TV and he said The
Apprentice um so I um I finished off my
fifth pint and took my jovial half drunk
self up and filled out the application
form and wi forward 6 months you know
flights to and from London doing
interviews and doing all this
preparation I'm sat outside the studio
for Series 2 in the UK ready to go on
the show like who was hosting it at that
point Alan sugar Lord Alan sugar you're
fired yeah okay so anyway um the
producers are coming in and coming out
and they're coming you're going on
you're going on you're you're not going
on just yet just just just stay there so
after 4 hours of this they say look I'm
really sorry but you're not going on the
show just now and we'll fly you back to
Scotland and I'm like I mean I've told
the whole island I'm going that's all
eight people in the dog um I've told the
whole island I'm going on this show I
can't go back there so I got to uh the
airport and I saw oh look next flight
going to IA that's a good place to get
over rejection so headed out to IA put
my bags literally put my bags into check
in Space the
nightclub that's a very alcoholic move
stayed there for 3 years three days
rather only like a like that's something
I would have done yeah I I get it yeah
[__] it yeah I'm not going back I don't
want to face those people who I made
this promise to I'm going to go here
where I can you know kind of just drown
myself in whatever and distract myself
exactly full on distraction coping um
and so in in IB I bumped into an oil
broker and told him my story and he was
like you should come as one does in a be
oh there's loads of Oil Brokers out
there
often um and he said you should come and
try oil broken um so I that's how I
found myself down in London as an oil
broker I used to say to my boss David
God bless him um I used to say you know
I didn't get hired by Alan sugar but I
did get hired by you and he would say
Riri there are two types of people who
go onto The Apprentice one have some
form of business Acumen and the other's
good at TV which are you and I was like
definitely good at TV
David there you go so the days of
becoming an oil
broker we would call it an oil Trader
here right well Trader broker slightly
different similar oh different doesn't
matter who cares the broker's the
middleman yeah but this is you know Andy
you know Andy explained that lifestyle
pretty clearly but lay it out because I
you know it's it's it's it's very much a
Wolf of Wall Street sort of experience
right like you know I thought the days
of liquid lunches had gone the way of
the dodo but apparently not in this
subculture of Finance absolutely not
well not when I started which was is now
gosh how long 20 years ago more I'm
getting old um so um to uh 18 years
ago um yeah I think when I when I
started in it people were like oh the
good old days are gone now but you know
when I started on that desk I started
with the senior guys and they're all
bored they don't want to go out and
entertain they've had enough in crude
like the biggest desk the world you know
the world's largest oil brokerage and
they were like okay your job is to
entertain our clients so I was like okay
well my budget's gone from five grand a
month to 20 now that's great because I'm
doing everybody else's entertainment so
I got really really good at it I mean
you know I was the only guy to get 250
men into a nightclub last minute um you
know like just I knew all the bouncers I
knew the good restaurants I knew where
the places to go so yeah it was it was
amazing fun it was wild um but the
drinking was huge uh let me give you
another example we go out we go out for
a lunch like you said down to the Curry
House and I'm drinking all the way
through and you know Andy and I used to
be thick thick as thieves right so while
he's doing little magic tricks over
there making himself levitate and making
a fool of himself I'm busy topping up
people's pints with either vodka or
champagne right to to get them more
smashed and um then next minute I'm
looking down at my phone and I'm like
it's the window now the window is when
our office with 15 people in or you know
15 people around a desk all shout at
each other to set the crude oil price
now 85% of the world's oil is set as a
benchmark to that and the vast majority
of us have all come back from lunch
absolutely Blotto and here we are
setting the world's crude oil price
that's what it used to be like yeah so
this is not happening at 10:00 at night
this is in the middle of the afternoon
oh yeah this is at 4:30 p.m. well it
used to be so um and you know another
crude example is oh crude nice pun there
rui um I remember taking some customers
out to lunch um and my thing always used
to be let's do whiskey tasting so you
know we'd have lunch and then we'd do
some whiskies and I'm sitting there
having having those whiskies and next
minute I put it down and I'm like oh my
God it's
5:30 I'm supposed to be at my NCT class
which is basically newborn child classes
my wife is pregnant and I'm supposed to
be there and I looked at my phone and
I'm like quick go shoot home you know
smashed and go to my first parent class
class yeah so that's not a good look no
it's not a good look but you've got a
lot of examples of you you know telling
your wife that you're going to be home
at six or 7 o'clock and then showing up
at 5 o'clock in the morning yeah exactly
yeah um and then there's you know I
think that begets itself there's a lot
of people who swing past the pub rather
than go home um in fact you know we use
a a wonderful heart monitor to show
people's central nervous system right so
they can see minute by minute where
they're in sympathetic or Paras
sympathetic and you know recently
somebody's like the most stressed I get
is when I go home and I have to deal
with the kids like I'm actually fine at
work and then that stress absolutely
spikes in the evening and so like that
it would come to shall I go home or
shall I go to the pub and pretend that
the train was delayed you know I worked
with a guy right who used to do the
night the the the clothes that time when
they set the price used to be 7:30 p.m.
it took him 2 years before before he
told his wife that the time had changed
to
4:30 it's not a great look when you
don't want to go home no well that's
happened I think that happens to all of
us sometimes sometimes well maybe not
all of us but I think many of many many
many people out there will swing by
somewhere before they go home just for a
little sharpener just for a little quiet
one before they go home they need to
take the edge off the day and then and
before they go home and and face that
and with these things
often you know they're creating it
that's that's the thing with alcohol it
not only is used as the solution but
actually creates it in the first place
right so you know you feel stressed out
but alcohol is causing stress it's
creating more stress your relationship
as an example well you feel like you
need a drink because of your
relationship but your drinking is
causing problems on the relationship and
this is what it's like with so many
areas of our life I mean it's not just
the drinking it's the lying and then the
erosion of trust and the unreliability
and the unpredictability all of that
there's a Cascade of you know dominoes
that all fall as a result of that and
there's a difference between the person
who goes to the pub and has one pop
maybe you shouldn't do that maybe you'd
be better off if you didn't do that
versus the person who goes to the pub on
the way home fully convinced that
they're still going to make that train
and be home on time and shows up at 5:00
in the morning exactly which would be
you know I'm that guy yeah it sounds
like were periodically that yeah I was a
bit in in that guy um and and you know
certainly causing significant disruption
in in life but I think for a lot of
people you know they say I'm not that
guy I'm not and I and I won't be I think
a lot of people in in in the
preventative space are are kidding
themselves in part with that they're
like I'll never I'm not going to well
there's always somebody who's worse you
can always point to somebody who's
further down the line and say I'll never
be that person or at least I'm not doing
that and those are all crutches is to
reinforce the you know the the unhealthy
Behavior pattern that you're trying to
protect yeah and all the people who are
down that end of the line the vast
majority of them say I don't know how I
got here you know it crept up it just
started to creep up and creep up sure
launching this business um was an
amazing thing when we when we when we
got inspired like Andy coming on talking
about the challenge and why the
challenge why the challenge Works um why
that is so significant for people
because I'd spent a long time trying to
be you know Evangelical standing out
there in padilly Circus with the you
know with the with the Bell here ye here
ye stop drinking it's amazing you know
and everyone's like shut up go to the
pub um and so that's where the challenge
fit in so beautifully because it was
like hey this is cool this is something
to be proud of right you want to be
fitter faster healthier happier you want
to be a better dad you want to be a
better husband all of those things you
want to be a better Mom this is um from
The Challenge so um I think when it when
it sort of really came into was um
probably been a a year of investing in
this right hundreds of thousands of
pounds invested into this business um
and I sent a tweet out to a
journalist and um they got I got into a
bit of a conversation and off the back
of that we got a 10-minute feature in
BBC World News in over 200 countries
kind of unheard of for a business to get
that kind of exposure but um it was
amazing and a friend of mine called me
up in ital and he said ruri I've just
seen you on the news I think what you're
doing is amazing I'm meeting the Dalai
Lama next week would you like to meet
him right just a quick check my diary
let's have a
look wow so um so I flew over to Pisa
and very random you know when
Serendipity and things like that show up
you know you're on the right path right
so next minute all sorts of things
happen and I'm standing on this stage
asking the Daly Lama a question in front
of thousands of people in Pisa like just
unbelievable so I asked him I said and I
just wondered what your advice would be
to anyone who is trying to get control
of their
addictions and he
said
if
we teach our younger
generation uh how to develop inner
peace and how to De when negative
emotion come then I think uh through
systematic sort of method
teaching a future generation could be
better that's my B so I just
thought old Huntly
appreciate are people like you who
really try to help such people wonderful
what we need to do is help children to
feel their emotion now this is the Dal
Lama's really big thing right right this
is the ultimate prevention because if we
can help our kids feel more emotion we
can prevent all these things but when he
said that to me I was like okay I
remembered back to the letter to Branson
right I remembered back about this this
purpose about this being about why I was
on here and I was like this is it I I
know why I've been put on this planet
it's it's to spread this message um and
I went in on Monday morning and handed
in my notice an oil broker my boss said
to me what are you doing like you you
got a successful de you can they'd let
me spend 70% of my time for 2 years
building the business on the side they
were like just carry on take the money I
can't do another day that day is the
worst financial decision I ever made so
far yeah walking away from you know a
really well-paid career where they're
actually supportive of you building this
other thing on the side exactly and they
were they were so supportive they saw
what what impact it was having but when
you're treading you know those two
worlds you're preventing yourself from
really accessing the growth that's
possible if you go all in on this thing
so it was a test there's also something
else really pertinent and important
meaning and purpose is a huge driver of
compulsive Behavior okay so if you are
misaligned to who you are in meaning and
purpose and you're doing something that
you feel is completely meaningless but
you're doing it for the money I'm
telling you right now it is rotting you
inside yeah and I didn't realize right
that this daily this drinking this all
this Behavior like I was commuting to
via VIA tube to a windowless office
right I'm born on an island near the sea
right the environment was wrong the you
know what my boss used to say to me used
to say every day there's a pot of gold
put on the table and you just have to
reach in and grab whatever's yours and
that was the purpose that was what we
did and inside me was so much more right
I knew I knew that I could help people
like my dad telling me you're special
you're gifted I was like I'm wasting
this right I I I need to help people and
when it comes to this message
rid you know I have been tested with
this business beyond
all belief uh building a business is so
hard this is the hardest thing I've ever
done and through that Journey I've been
questioned so many times like why you
know why didn't you go back to oil
Brooking you made so much more money you
had a better lifestyle you all of those
things why why why don't you just make a
nice little small thing and not really
you know a nice little lifestyle all of
those tests have come along the the line
and I've asked myself and said you know
why are you doing this and it came down
to something really powerful and that is
if some words out of my mouth can help
somebody who is regularly drinking
alcohol to reconsider their relationship
with it to take the first step to
changing that relationship I can change
not only their life not only their
family's life their their relationships
their their businesses like and that's
it for me and well also the maybe most
importantly their relationship with
their kids yeah 100% and and create a
situation in which their kids are not
you know victimized by that person's
trauma and as a result grow up healthier
and liberated from the cycle of
addiction that destroys so many families
[Music]
exactly Julie what would you say to
somebody who comes to you and says you
know what I find your lifestyle or the
way that you eat really aspirational but
I'm too busy I just don't have time I
don't want to be cracking open cookbooks
and trying to learn a new skill when I'm
already exhausted after a long day how
do you guide this person where should
they go the plant power meal planner is
really really such an amazing value it
is under $2 a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration knowhow and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients uh the shopping list and
then the support from all of the coaches
that we have available to answer all of
your questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plant-based meals and to
Kickstart our health intentions this New
Year we're offering you $2 off a
one-year membership with the code power
20 throughout the entire month of
January to learn more and to sign up go
to meals. Rich roll.com again that's
promo code power20 for $20 off at
meals.
roll.com
[Laughter]
we skipped over the part though where
you finally decide to put it down you
finally decide to stop drinking yeah
yeah that came about because I got a
text message from my wife
um and uh saying you know I'll be in
I'll be in Sweden with our daughter and
I knew that that's her putting her foot
down which didn't really stop me in fact
I took it up a notch um but what
happened is um interestingly with Andy's
story he mentioned that a decade ear or
a whole bunch of years earlier I'd given
him the book which started everything
right started the whole transformation
and that was awaken the giant within
Tony Robins and similarly he had said to
me you know why don't you try this thing
called headspace and that was 20 3 so I
just started meditating and I used it as
when I'm on the train and I'm trying to
change who I am from the person I needed
to be to survive in that business to
going home to a loving family that I was
trying to grow good humans so I I did it
on the train and that's when the
scratching started to get stronger and
stronger and stronger and I think that's
what it is for people right I think
people just have a little scratch at the
back of their head which is like hey
this alcohol thing it is holding you
back and and I think sometimes they have
it quite loud on Sunday morning like oh
Fu now alcohol's really holding me back
but other times it's just a scratch so
when I started meditating that's when
that scratch started to grow um and it
was growing and growing growing to the
point where I was like you know what I
think I'm going to take a break told my
boss I was doing it he said you are
committing commercial suicide if you
stop drinking well first of all just to
be totally clear here it's interesting
like okay meditation head space the Tony
Robbins book your relationship with
Andy but leading up to that there was an
incident in which you didn't come home
until 5:00 in the morning the train and
your wife had had enough and she said
I'm out of here she's Swedish she's
she's leaving she's going back to Sweden
um and this was precipitated correct me
if I'm wrong um by you also like sharing
with her a selfie of you leaning your
head out the window of a speeding train
while you were you know hammered
thinking it was a good idea and fun yeah
yeah that that article made the paper um
I know I saw it and but people are like
your eyes your eyes in that photo you
know that there's emphasis on like you
know the air going into your cheeks but
I look at the eyes and I'm like this
guy's gone yeah uh that was that was on
the way home to the NCT class um um to
first time as as a dad um and could have
fun that that photo ended up in all
these sort of British
tabloid Publications I'm very happy with
that yeah yeah I will I mean not that
I'll do anything um we have to be
careful what I say but um again if that
sharing that that
that crazy person that I was and by the
way when people say to me that is so
crazy I'm like that's the test thing I
did right the other not on video it
doesn't seem like it's not yeah I mean
I've surfed roofs of cars I lost all the
skin on my arm I've I mean no let's not
go into the who's who I'm sure you've
got some Tales of debauchery but that
was the sort of instigating set of
circumstances that you into saying like
I go to I got to find a way to rectify
this they were they were building but
those things were again were all
normalized and I think this is where a
lot of people are right where they can
hang their head out of a train and um
send the message to everyone and
everyone just be like that's hilarious
right or you know something end up in
A&E and everyone be like you were so
smashed last night you know that's
hilarious um and it's the it's the near
misses it's the nearly thing and I think
for people it's in there like they know
this is not right they know it's costing
them a bit but then there's something
stopping them from that change and
that's the bit where we want to be there
to reach them and help them you know I
think prevention should always swim
upstream right so if we swim upstream
the most Upstream thing is The Hangover
so how can we how can we help people in
The Hangover to have better tools better
support better advice better guidance so
that they can prevent a more serious
relationship with alcohol
developing so you decide to put the
bottle down for a bit I did a year you
did a year at what point do you bump
into Andy though and realize that he
independent of you was doing the same
thing uh just around about 90day Mark
Mark um and he he was more he was like
four or five months in and um he said he
said I think I'm going to do my 40th
birthday and not drink and I was
like Andy thick as thieves
Andy um and he did he he messaged me
afterwards about how amazing he felt
doing it so I was like okay well I've
got my birthday coming up and I've got
Christmas I'm going to do those and
that's where the momentum builds you
know you don't you don't you don't sit
out at the beginning going right I'm
going to do a year it's going to be
awesome I think I think you do it bit by
bit by step you had an accountability
buddy yeah sort of thep the the the bill
and Dr Bob you know analogy yeah sort of
in your own version yeah exactly um and
uh yeah and that I think that's that we
we sort of got together and we were like
you know we need to do something about
this we need to inspire more people and
yeah that's that's where we came up bir
to the whole thing and so how did that
go from an idea into actually being like
a thing that other people that you
enlisted other people into participating
in well hundreds of thousands of pounds
of my own
money I mean you know I'm looking
forward to writing a book one day 10,000
one things not to do when starting a
business um and um because I just made
all of all of the mistakes um you know
through the time we had the challenge we
kind of focused on that and then it came
to a moment where okay let's take this
big let's raise some money um and that's
something I wanted to do and we both had
different opinions there about whether
that was the right move um but you know
I I was here to impact the masses so I
knew we needed to raise some cash um and
somebody said to me you know why don't
you send out an email to your list see
maybe somebody knows somebody on there
so I wrote you know a powerful bit of
email like this is who we are this is
what we're trying to achieve this is
what the vision of where we're going is
is going to be do you know any sixf fig
investors out there who might help us
seed the round and I thought you know
shut the laptop went home I thought I
wonder if I'll come into a couple of
emails maybe somebody might know someone
I came in the next day to 74 emails we
raised 1.1 million in 5 weeks just from
our customers um and this was a thing
like oh my God and people would say to
me ruri even if I lose the 100 Grand I'm
investing in one year no beer it
wouldn't be equivalent to the value
you've given me and I was like wow this
is amazing like you know now in all of
those years we've raised over5 million
pounds all from our customers well one
one one external Joe desna oh Joe desna
good old Joe good for him he he he he
isn't a customer but I did have to I did
have to woo him I know that uh you guys
did a podcast recently I listened to
that but you were doing were you doing a
Spartan Race where were you in Iceland
or something something like that
randomly I got the a call to say um oh
you you're doing not drinking Joe will
love to hear from you you should talk to
Joe Des Santa so here here so they lined
up a call and I call Joe and I go hi Joe
uh he's right what do you want if you
can't say it in 6 minutes it's not worth
saying I'm like okay uh I'm Brewery one
your no beer he's like stop drinking
great idea you need to talk to my wife
one second talking to his wife and you
know obviously she's been put on the
spot anyway chat for a bit trying to
inspire her to to make a change which
Joe wanted to happen and then get back
on to him and I say Joe um I'd love to
do a podcast with you and he says okay
cool and I say I only do them in person
which is a lie but you know I wanted to
meet him and um he said okay I said I
can fly to Boston and he said um you
don't need to I'll be in Iceland in
December you can see me then and he
pretty much hangs up the phone and I get
off and I go it's a test Iceland Spartan
December Joe desna what pops up the
Spartan Ultra World Championships and
I'm like you know I know this guy he is
not going to even give me two seconds if
I don't enter this thing yeah you can't
go there and not do the race he's got
he's he's absolutely not going to have
any time for you so I did one lap of the
ultra um and uh but still that was that
was a serious thing and that kind of
kicked off a relationship a friendship
actually with Joe been very close to him
seeing you know spend a bit of time
together um and and um you know he well
Spartan was an investor an early
investor into one-year no beer and then
for a while we were at the finish line
of all of their events uh we were
supporting people there you know really
trying to inspire people to take a break
from alcohol so yeah it feels like a a
natural integration to an event series
like that in the same way that a brand
like athletic Brewing can be you know
kind of you yeah like embedded into that
to shift the the Paradigm away from like
oh you have a be after your race to no
we're actually doing something different
here exactly also one year no beer feels
like a uh like a package that any large
corporation you know would want to sort
of acquire and deploy with its with its
Workforce is that something that you
guys have done absolutely um the the the
corporate stuff is is is huge and I
think again in the preventative
conversation um with people is to say
hey we can just run a challenge together
with you guys and and um we can support
people through the challenge I think at
these organizations there's a lot of
people who uh will never raise their
hand and say I have an alcohol problem
in fact even today it's in some people's
contracts right if you have a problem
with alcohol we will fire you and so
it's like are you're putting people
under all of this pressure all of the
stress in world and yet the most readily
available tool for people dealing with
stress the one that we've been
conditioned and and programmed to deal
with and is literally everywhere
including many of the social events
organizations still to this day is
alcohol right so there are lots of
people with a poor relationship with
alcohol in these organizations who are
not going to raise their hand for fear
for stigma and so I think what we've
done is create a a simple tool for an
organization to use that helps us pick
all that up in the back end they don't
need to know they don't need to know
that one of their individuals had a more
intimate relationship with alcohol and
needed a bit more support they needed Co
they needed more you know whatever um
yeah it takes all that off the table it
just creates this welcome M where
there's no shame or stigma like Hey
we're doing this fun Challenge and then
people come in and it allows people who
maybe were thinking about how to do that
but terrified of being found out or
whatever uh you know all of those issues
are kind of like resolved yeah through
that I recently did a talk at a very
large Tech business um and it was a it
was a it was a it was a huge talk and it
was going around to the vast majority of
the organization so a lot of eyeballs
and um again it was all around this you
know do you want Optimal Health do you
want to be better and blah blah blah and
we'd had a guy who'd come through the
program and he was there giving his
conversation and it went to him and he's
like so I am significantly happier I am
more driven than I've ever been in my
entire 30-year career in this
organization I have more clarity more
Focus my wife is telling me she's more
in love with me than she's ever been I'm
calmer as a parent with my kids I'm more
productive I know I'm doing better deals
in fact last night I was out at one of
my client dues and I know I would be
absolutely hanging today if it wasn't
for this program and you listen to that
and you're like how is not every
organization investing in that right now
why is everybody not going all in in on
that it baffles me it's baffled me for 9
years so yeah I mean what are the
barriers there I mean you I think you
you we came right up to it but then you
didn't actually say it which was when
you when you decided to stop drinking
and your boss said this is career
suicide what in fact happened was you
expanded your book by 50% exactly right
so your productivity went through the
roof through the roof which must have
been amazing for your boss to Bear
witness to right like
he he still wanted to deny it in a way
um but you know yeah those those those
those stats of increasing business I was
the only broker who wasn't pissed on
Friday and the only broker who wasn't
literally suicidally depressed on Monday
and Tuesday because um I wasn't drinking
alcohol given the fact that sorry given
the fact that that culture is so
oriented around drinking yeah how did
you overcome the social triggers there
to be able to do that without all of
your colleagues and the clients wanting
nothing to do with you because you were
suddenly doing things differently
absolutely step it up a notch change it
right recognize what you're actually
trying to achieve so for me I wanted to
build good relationships um that was
really key I don't have a high turnover
of customers I actually build these
relationship with customers and then you
know for your career you you work with
those individual
so I changed up how I did things I mean
I ran a relay race at the Olympic
Stadium um and that relay race had 40
guys and gals involved in and every
weekend people would be doing Park runs
together and talking about PBS for
months before the event at the Olympic
Stadium which everyone was looking
forward to that built way better
relationships with people I used to take
people cycling which is why I live in
mior so I took people cycling the man
therapy you can have have grinding up a
hill grinding is probably the wrong word
but that you can have sitting on that
bicycle going up a hill having a
conversation with somebody about real
life about the the truth of stuff not
the fickle tiny conversations that all
Brokers are having at 3:00 in the
morning that they can't really recommend
like real genuine connection so I think
that's it was about stepping it up a
notch and I mean we've talked about this
before I also had to stealth drink right
which you know it's we live in a world
where you might have to stealth drink
but this is true right meaning you would
you would have a drink that looked like
an alcoholic drink that wasn't just so
you could Dodge that bullet yeah exactly
yep and um nobody would know and you
become a master of it um I remember this
one time I sit down I get there early
and I tell the barman and I say look I'm
not drinking I tip him 50 Quid and I say
whatever they bring out it's alcohol
free right so um he's like okay sure no
I've got you covered an income Big C
customer right they love their booze and
they're expecting booze to be to be well
had um beers everyone yep yep yep cool
so they come along they PL down a pint
plot down a pint plot down a pint plot
down a pint plot pint everyone's got
their pints next minute he comes up to
me and he's literally carrying a
sequined flowery glass with a little
handle on it right and then an
alcohol-free beer which has got dust on
it and he plonks the two in front of me
like this and I'm like you [__]
idiot so I have to go what get rid of
this and give me a
point how was the pandemic for all of
this what did you learn about people's
behavior during the pandemic and and the
organization and the community of people
um yeah the pandemic decimated society's
relationship with alcohol um I speak to
people every single day who say that's
when it went up a notch um and people
haven't been able to get it back down
they haven't been able to um reduce
because it was just so shocking it was
um it was it was trauma um and so I
think you know that has been very
detrimental to people the vast majority
of people will mention the pandemic um
as a as a as when it started to get
worse um for the organization something
utterly beautiful happened so when we
were all stuck at home and initially
kicked off um
I could see that we had all of these
workers we had these health staff NHS
out there in amongst this craziness
right and relying on alcohol because
it's the tool to deal with stress and
difficulties I mean the amount of
doctors and nurses and surgeons who come
through our program you'd be shocked so
I said look hey Community we have an
opportunity to do good here are you
willing to come back like come back into
the community engage significantly if we
open our doors for free to all NHS staff
health workers and and emergency workers
and the response was unbelievable I mean
well over 10,000 people like yep I'm in
I'm in it was
unbelievable and so we opened up our
doors for free um and we just had this
huge powering and I I I was actually
speaking to a nurse the other day and
she was like I signed up during that
program and it's the only thing that got
me through it was being a part of your
community and that was my that was my
vice that was my addiction the the the
the Facebook group and the and the
community was the the release yeah I
mean certainly alcohol sales went up
during that period alcohol consumption
went up during that period but I think
your your signups went up like 30% or
something like that during that period
of time yeah is uh the the the the world
was divided there were people who fell
down the bottle and and and use an
excuse and there were people are like
right I'm going to use this as an
opportunity to change you see the big
thing in there is um when we change our
environment uh our brain is kicked into
neuroplasticity so it's easier for us to
change behavior when we change
environment so that's why it was for
some people when they were like right no
I'm going to get on top of this and I'm
going to make a difference and I think
for lots of people who did some of the
work and made the changes in their life
they've remained having a healthier or
non-existent alcohol-free relationship
with alcohol and I think some people
have found it creep back um since doing
that work and so of all the people that
have gone through your program what uh
what do the statistics say about people
who continue to not drink versus people
who did the challenge then resume some
semblance of their previous lifestyle
like what is the staying power of these
kind of challenges and how long do you
have to do it before you see an increase
in the sustainability of a new way of
pursuing your
life I so when you look at the challenge
as an example um the vast majority of
people come and they do a 28 day
challenge because it's the one that only
seemen perceivable and then they go back
to drinking for a bit and then they do
the 90-day Challenge and then they might
go back to drinking for a little bit and
then they go back to a year um and this
is why I wanted to change things up
because
I what I see in that is that people are
drinking and then they go back not just
to drinking but probably it starts to
creep back into a problematic way and
some people that can get worse and worse
and worse and that's why we had to step
up the availability of tools and
resources to support people in a deeper
fashion because they in a way the
challenge is just like this light touch
element of hey let's let's just give
this a shot um and getting people to
really do the work on changing the
things that are driving it that is with
every fiber of my being that is how we
really really help people like how let's
talk about emotions right have you ever
been taught to deal with your emotions
what about stress what what tools do you
use to mitigate stress like um other
than just reaching for alcohol you know
do you meditate do you exercise uh do
you do breath work you know when you
come out of a board meeting in the
afternoon and it's been stressful for
you you do you reach for a coffee which
significantly delays your ability to
return into recovery or do you just do
some breath work to give yourself the
same Elation but then bring yourself
back into parasympathetic so I think
people don't have these tools they don't
even have the awareness they don't have
the understanding and so getting people
through that experience giving them the
tools to actually mitigate that
compulsion that's what gives them a far
better chance um of of longevity of
changing their relationship with alcohol
from a sales perspective though it's a
harder sell than to just say it's a 28
day challenge people understand that you
know intuitively what that means um and
then you're now introducing like well
actually it's complicated and here's all
this stuff this is very difficult to
scale and to sell to somebody who's like
listen man I just want to drink less
like I I I don't need to go into my
childhood with you yeah let's not talk
about that on the front cover right
let's go back to the 28 day challenge
and let's start there um because in all
of this stuff we're going to help you to
start to see that there are these things
um and I think it's a a gradual thing
right it's the cooking of the Frog right
do it little by little gentle by gentle
and the Frog will not jump out right um
I think it's the frog or the lober
example boiling the Frog boiling yeah
you got to boil a frog slowly so this is
where we're meeting people at right
let's just start going on this journey
let's look at this as a journey of
changing your relationship ship with
alcohol and it might take you a few
years right it might take it might be
faster than that but on that Journey
we're going to keep making changes in
your life personal development changes
we're going to help you with these
various things and we're going to help
you to have a improved relationship with
alcohol along with all the benefits of
that and all the work that you've done
around the behavioral psychology piece
of this what have you learned about the
difference
between breaking a bad habit and forming
a new habit and and and where does that
understanding inform how you craft these
programs or how you kind of approach
somebody who's thinking about making a
change wonderful question the first part
here is um Professor BJ fog Stanford
University wonderful human being changed
his relationship with alcohol his
research says we change Behavior by
feeling good not by feeling bad and so
looking at everything that we do here
it's about being positive aspirational
right oh I want that I want to be fitter
I want to be lose weight I want to be
happier I want to be healthier right so
if we stay in that positive psychology
Focus going towards a direction of
aspiration then I think that's where we
meet the vast majority of people in
changing a bad habit rather than you
have a problem and that kind of language
let's stay in this um part of habit
change the second part he says is bad
habits are like weeds okay so they grow
over time they start to infect different
areas of your brain they infect your
reward system your identity your belief
system your emotions okay so do you
Garden no lucky
man but if you've ever pulled out a weed
right if you just go and rip it out then
it grows back and usually it'll grow
back worse which is why we actually have
to go through the process of cultivating
it out what do we do to do that we
cultivate good habits good habits is how
we remove a bad habit and so that's why
during all of that the the the challenge
and all of these other programs we're
pretty ruthless in helping people uh
build habits the habit of meditation the
habit of exercise the habit of sleeping
well the habit of eating well um the
habit of uh gratitude journaling like
these are the tools that we use to help
people my um anecdotal observation on
this which is not clinical in the least
is that people who have a normal like a
quote unquote like kind of normal
relationship with the world and
themselves which is to say they are not
they are not um you know addicts by
Nature they don't have that addictive
impulse those people seem to
have the capacity to crowd out bad
habits by focusing on cultivating new
positive habits and as a result of kind
of investing their energy and their
enthusiasm in these new positive habits
the bad habits sort of you know they
just end up falling away this is
something my wife is very good at and
this is also something that I look at
with great curiosity because I cannot do
this how do you do that this is not how
I'm wired in the least and that's
because fundamentally my wiring is
different I am wired with a very you
know powerful inclination towards
addictive behaviors and things that
don't serve me and so that understanding
allows me to to approach this
differently to say that probably is
going to work for me it's good to
cultivate positive habits but I have to
like do triage on the bad habit like I
have to address it as the dangerous
acute thing that it is and no matter how
much I pull those weeds out they're
always going to grow back unless I dig
them out completely and make sure that
every little every little yeah like
tentacle of yeah is gone right and that
requires you know a lot of effort and
diligence and and and persistence to do
that so I guess what I'm getting at is
is that fundamental difference between
the person who's wired in that kind of
addictive construct versus the more kind
of normal average person if there ever
was one and and wondering how through
the course of working with so many
people through this program you begin to
identify who the people are who might
need that more kind of acute redress of
the issue that they're contending with
that a 28-day challenge is not going to
resolve and is there then kind of a
pathway to guide them towards um a
recovery modality that they might be
more suited towards because I see all of
this
as complimentary to 12ep like exactly
look there is there there are many ways
to get sober regardless of your problem
I'm not here to say otherwise and and of
course I have my own biases and I'm very
much indoctrinated in the 12 step and
believe in it and have borne witness to
thousands of people who have reimagined
their lives in in miraculous ways and
overcome you know just the most drastic
of circumstances to become incredible
people so I'm always you know the first
to
say you know if you think you have a
problem you should go check that out and
suspend whatever judgments you have or
whatever you saw in whatever movie that
made you think one way or the other
about what this program may or may not
be um and I also understand that it's
not for everybody and if you do have
just a casual relationship with drinking
maybe you you know AA is not the place
for you um but I'm just curious around
the hard cases that I'm sure find their
way into your program absolutely um and
then what happens with those individuals
okay um well we take great care is the
first thing um let me tell you about
Keith right so Keith three attempts at
The Priory the F first time he went to
The Priory which is 10 of thousands of
pounds by the way to go to the prior The
Priory being a a treatment center the
treatment center one of the the
treatment center for wealthy people in
uh the UK or in
London the first time he goes to the
prior it's a week later he's back into
problematic drinking the second time
it's probably a couple of weeks right it
it very quickly went back to problematic
drinking I recently spoke to him so he
came on our complete control program a
year ago okay and he's one of our
greatest Advocates he's like I just
don't feel like it right he says I
occasionally have a drink right but most
of the time I just don't feel like it I
don't have that that same cognitive load
now the thing is he would absolutely
traditionally you'd say he is over here
and yet we have been successful with
helping him change this okay let's ask
each other again in 5 years and 10 years
and see where he is but I think the
greatest thing that about him is he is
now on such a path of self-discovery I
mean he's currently deep in psychedelics
and learning about going through trauma
and discovered he had significant
childhood trauma which did on the
program and he's now in this full
personal development mode of making huge
changes in his life kicked off from this
trajectory of
saying hey maybe maybe there's more to
this maybe if you try changing some of
these things here this thing might go
down or go away for you a little bit
right so really what I'm saying
is there is no black and white there is
no he needs to go here or she needs to
go there there is just why don't we look
at the lifestyle things why don't we
look at the things that we know that all
the science out there says to us that
drives compulsive Behavior like stress
like trauma like emotions like
connection to people like meaning and
purpose why don't we address all of
these things with them and then ask that
question right let's give the example of
depression right somebody feels
depressed they go into the doctor they
say I feel depressed
now the doctor may or may not ask them
about their relationship with alcohol
the doctor will most likely or the
psychiatrist will most likely prescribe
them a medication for their
depression but every day they are
drinking the world's most powerful
depressant and you're not like hang on
what about sleep let's ask them are you
sleeping because we now know that sleep
deprivation is I mean well we know it's
used as torture right so sleep
deprivation is a significant driver of
compulsive behavior all these people who
are working shift work and late nights
and things like that right what about
mental health what about ADHD and things
like that have they been taught how to
regulate their central nervous system no
they've never been taught that well
that's why they're using alcohol because
they've never been taught how to
regulate their nervous system are they
right so are they exercising are they
running that conversation is not
happening it's here's a pill or you have
a problem you need to go here and I
think let's just start with this
conversation of okay if it's not the
challenge then why don't we look at
these things together let's look at them
with a fine toothcomb actually we use
some cool technology the aura ring
things like that uh we help them see in
data and evidence and Clarity and then
we sit at the end of the program and we
have this wonderful traffic light system
and it shows our core drivers we go
through all of the data we've captured
all of the evidence and of those core
drivers there's red Amber and green if
there's lots of Reds then absolutely
whatever you do stay alcohol-free you
must move those things from Red into
Amber before even considering trying to
control your drinking which is what they
came in for in the beginning um so I
think we give people Clarity and
understanding on what they need to do in
order to have a better relationship with
alcohol I'm using the word better that
being said let's say you came through
that program and once again it comes
back to you absolutely you need to go to
a treatment center or you need to go to
12st step or you need to find the next
thing um and I but I just think that
this is a part where we can help people
earlier all the apps that are available
now and The Trackers are are really
effective I think it in in reconfiguring
people's relationship to alcohol because
you mentioned the aura ring or you have
a whoop um and you can just show people
what the data looks like like here's
here's what here's what your night was
like last night after two glasses of
wine and their HRV is you know beneath
the floor and their resting heart rate
is higher way higher than normal and
their respiratory rate is off and the
lack of deep sleep and REM sleep like
it's just right there and I think those
those interfaces are so effective at
showing the DraStic difference between
what the previous night's sleep which
was healthy looks like in comparison and
I think shocks that's very effective at
shocking people out of whatever they've
convinced themselves like when you can
actually see what your body is doing how
it's responding to that it it reframes
the whole thing and it gives people an
entry point like they don't really have
to contend with the fact that whether
whether or not they have a problem
they're just like I need to sleep better
and in order to sleep better I need to
do this this is it it's like different
things speak to different people you
mentioned weight loss that's another one
obviously but well building building a
more successful business you know I mean
um Alex Orosi out there saying you know
absolutely I I stopped drinking it was
the best thing everything shot up from
then the this this the the stopping
drinking was the was the Catalyst for
huge transformation for me and to have
some you know big influencer like that
talking about it in that way I think
that's going to reach so many more
people they're like oh I want to double
my business this year but the difference
with like the whoop is like it's
literally immediate like it's overnight
you can see this yes build your business
over time you had a 50% increase like
these things are real but they're
stories told by somebody else they're
not direct experiences that can be had
in a you know literally in a period of a
couple hours exactly I mean your man
Blake behind the camera there was saying
exactly the same thing it was he was
looking at it on his whoop and he was
like hang on a minute this is really
costing me yeah um and as a new dad
youve got enough sleep deprivation
without having al already everything's
stacked against you as it is already so
explain to me what this complete control
program is all about completely yes
complete control this is confusing to me
go ahead bear with me Rich we're doing
good good we're doing good things um
okay so again born off the research um
you know what I saw was a lot of people
like myself who took a break from
alcohol and then went back to
problematic drinking so I knew there was
more to this like I I knew there was
more in the underlying um and what I
wanted to do is help people in a more uh
intimate way right so what would that
look like as we sat down as a team so
you know we have successfully unlocked
the greatest um product ever sold by
onee no beer is equity right that was
that was the greatest product we ever
sold and so if we look at this for
serving a different audience and a more
impactful way what is it right what is
it to to help people understand what
drives compulsive Behavior can can
somebody control their drinking well I
mean I have I've been able to
successfully control my drinking I
usually choose not to drink I
occasionally have a drink I had a very
problematic relationship with alcohol I
know thousands and thousands and
thousands of people who've gone on that
same journey and been able to achieve
the same thing so what is it to do that
so that's why we came up with something
which would help people understand with
Clarity what is actually driving it um
so the idea is to go through an 8we
program we use some pretty cool
technology we help people see their
stress I'm talking about seeing minute
by minute whether they're in sympathetic
or parasympathetic and being able to see
the impact that that is having on them
this is like one of the most impactful
parts of the program because the vast
majority of the people who come through
the program are very driven has had
celebrities on the program we've had MPS
very large business owners um director
world's largest banks you name it um And
when they see their stress in data like
this so clearly
but they also see how impactful alcohol
is when they have a drink it's very very
compelling for the change um so we take
them on this journey we help them
understand what is driving the behavior
and then we kind of Coach them through
trying to change those various areas of
their life when people come into the
program literally 100% of people are
looking for control they're like I don't
want to stop drinking I don't want to
stop I'm looking for control sure by the
end of and the joke that I told you is
that this is the this is the great adage
of you know the the great kind of
recursive Mantra of every good alcoholic
which is they they hold on to this
delusion this this uh this great desire
to be able to control their drinking to
drink like a gentleman so if we if we
take just one two 10 five 10% of those
people and we Chang them and actually
achieve that is that not
success it's success only to the extent
that the people who really need more
acute help are are not um deprived of
that because they're trying to
perpetuate the delusion that this is
possible for them well and in that case
yeah then it would be then then it's
problematic but what we're doing what we
do with it is say okay thank you so much
for coming in and looking for control
now let's have a look at your life these
are the areas of your life that you need
to change now the program is
life-changing because we're going to
show people the areas of their life that
they need to change right that we're
going to start doing some trauma work
for the vast majority of people who come
into here they've never done any trauma
work they've never done any talk therapy
like it that in itself is hugely
positive right to take somebody who's
looking for control of their drinking
and then bring them to the table to
start dealing with this childhood [__]
that they've been ignoring and packing
down their whole life that's success or
what about and we talk about stress a
lot right what what about teaching them
how to deal with a much higher level of
stress um I've had a guy who built half
a billion turnover business and he's
like I had no idea right that I needed
to integrate these tools into my day and
that I had no idea of the capacity of
stress I could handle until a I removed
the vast majority of my drinking and I'm
talking about the vast majority right he
now rarely drinks we caught up with him
in mior he flew over by private jet to
take my wife and I out to dinner and
he's like I I'm going to be out here for
15 days and maybe on one day I'll have a
drink or two the rest I've just got
absolutely no interest and so this is
what happens when you show people the
impact of stress the impact of trauma
the impact of these things they can
change those things so um yeah I think
wrapped up inside hey is alcohol causing
a bit of trouble in your life is it
something that you've struggled to to
change and it keeps coming back let's
let's look at some areas of your life
and and shift those and see if that
finally does it for you sure yeah I get
that and I I I totally understand that I
think in the the board game
of sobriety and abstinence if one is to
uh you know pursue this path of of
complete control and realize time and
time again that they find themselves out
of control it's uh maybe time to not
pass go and maybe not go to jail but go
to step one which is to embrace the fact
that you are powerless over this
substance and that your life is
unmanageable yeah because the real
premise of 12ep is acknowledging your
inability to control this this thing
that that you know persists to the level
of astonishment yeah absolutely and it's
been hugely successful well it's been it
has
been it has been one of the most
important things in society for a long
time for helping people change their
relationship with alcohol and I think
where we're coming at this from is just
to to widen up that story to widen up
that Gap to widen up that story to say
look people are different and you don't
know what might be the Catalyst for
finally changing somebody for finally
them putting it down for good for
finally making the changes in their life
or their business whatever it is they
need to do you don't know what that
catalyst will be for some people You
Never Know Rich it could be this podcast
right it could be somebody listening to
this and they've had a significantly
problematic relationship with alcohol
and they go do you know what [__] this
I'm done and in that moment they decide
to go and make these changes in their
life and go on a personal development
journey and I don't know go to take some
iasa or do iboga which I've done nuts by
the way but and iboga be the thing that
stops them which is very powerful at
doing so we just don't know what will be
the Catalyst for somebody and I think
when we open up that conversation to say
there are other tools and a wide
arrangement of tools and we have to
treat people like that and I think
similarly that's the conversation in
society right is it is what at what
level is the problem at what level does
the person have to admit there is a
problem and if we turn that conversation
around and say let's not have a
conversation about it being a problem
but let's just say is alcohol causing
you problems because if it is why don't
you change your relationship with it mhm
what have you learned about the
relationship between ADHD and
alcohol yeah
99.9999999% of people who come to
complete control either identify with or
are ADHD add or neurode Divergent um my
own personal journey of understanding my
incredibly destructive Behavior derived
from
ADHD like a nuclear bomb is been so
intrinsic in helping
me understand other people and deliver a
program which is helping people change
significantly ADHD and that coping
mechanism of alcohol are so
intrinsically linked when we look at
this in the data right what happens with
ADHD is we get that hyperactivity okay
so imagine are you ADHD well I I asked
for personal reasons because I had never
thought once about whether or not I was
ADHD and I did a very intensive week of
trauma therapy last year right around
this time where I was what kind of
trauma therapy uh childhood trauma uh
and and basically every skilled
practitioner that saw me and I saw a
variety of them over the course of this
week all agreed there was a unanimous
consensus that I was ADHD but I was not
a hyperactive kid like it's a whole
different set of circumstances but go
ahead if if you don't feel hyperactive
as a kid than
add so um I there's there's a couple of
things into here don't let me lose track
there's a couple of things into
here if you look at the work by gabr
mate he says that actually ADHD add
things like that they're A coping
mechanism from a TR traumatized child
okay so um this past trauma then drives
us as a as an engine to create this
there's also some really interesting
studies out there showing that you know
um that uh ADHD is very much
intrinsically linked with sleep
deprivation sleep deprivation in babies
creates ADHD now my mom always said I
slept four hours and every 24 um as a
baby so I'm like oh thanks Mom you gave
me ADHD no so oh come on that's not
fair well there yeah exactly love you
mom um the
the thing about ADHD is imagine it's
like a a Dynamo you know when you push
the car like this and the the little
Dynamo you push and push and push it
goes off into the distance that's ADHD
right so our central nervous systems
they get wound up faster okay so the
stress that we bring into the day let's
say you drank last night or didn't sleep
well you then increase that level of
stress that you have and as you get into
this busyness the day you drink coffee
which is very impactful on our central
nervous system once again adds in more
stress is that we get up into this
hyperactive state which we love because
it makes us super busy in fact we can do
the work of 10 people in a day and we
pride ourselves in this ability to be
able to handle stress and do so much
work and be productive the problem comes
at the end of the day just like that
Dynamo we've been winding and winding
and winding and winding and winding
guess what the pre-ordained outcome is
your central nervous system needs to
numb out now and what is it well if it's
a coping mechanism for a traumatized
child then the truth is a lot of it is
emotion unprocessed dealt with emotion
which drives through our stress and
daily you know lots of daily activity
like that into a very busy brain and so
people go I just can't switch my brain
off and alcohol is the most readily
available tool out there for helping us
switch our brain off the issue is not
alcohol the the the thing is not the
problem what the issue is is a very
stressed out central nervous system
which is not being calmed down and so in
this here we're literally forcing people
to meditate I'm talking about monitoring
them every day and phoning them if they
don't meditate I call this the ass
kicker right when I said I want to
deliver a you're holding up an aura ring
for people who are just
listening so this is used for extreme
accountability because I get all these
business owners these high Achievers
these people coming in and they go I
just I mean I just tried to stop
drinking and it comes back and I'm like
yeah but what are you doing about your
stress well I'm very stressed yeah but
what are you do nothing so when we teach
them these tools and they calm down that
central nervous system that is when all
of the change happens you were talking
about doing trauma stuff meditation for
me is really I look at it like this and
some people might not like this but it
works for me I'm sick right I I'm ADHD
I'm sick if I do not take my medication
then I will get my ues out and I will
[__] my life up I'm like blow everything
up so I must medicate every day and my
medication is really simple it's
exercise and meditation um and so
helping people see it from that
perspective who they're like oh I tried
meditation but my brain is so busy just
can't switch it off yeah that's because
you need to
meditate super interesting yeah yeah I
have so much more I need to learn about
the world of ADHD just beginning to kind
of understand it my first step there and
the first step for me was to get ADHD
for dummies um I found it really
interesting do you know what it was is
it was hugely relieving to read about
this stuff of like oh so I'm not a
[__] weirdos we allowed to swear yeah
you can swear it's the same I have done
a little bit of reading and it is that
same experience when you go into an AA
meeting for the first time and think
you're the only one who has this
experience or or feels a certain way and
you hear your story recounted back to
you yeah exactly I felt that that that
that point of of relatability with what
I've learned so far did you feel that
the first time you went in there to
Alcoholics Anonymous yeah really yeah I
wasn't ready to do the work and I didn't
I didn't stay and I didn't get sober
immediately but I knew that I belong
there so I went to AA and I walked
straight back out and I was like I'm
this is not me and I hear this a l
contempt prior to investigation my
friend no but what I'm saying here is
that's I think the part is that you
identified immediately with it because
you recognize those conversations and
those stories and there are a lot of
people out there who are saying hey that
I don't resonate with that and I think
that's the importance of having this
smorgus Board of tools and conversations
and things like that to meet people
where they're at I get that but I also
think it's important to to
to um encourage people to set aside
their prior convictions and their
judgments because often those are
misplaced yeah and I think people go in
with
um already you know predisposed to not
like it and the minute something happens
that that they can like hang their hat
on that they're out the door and they're
like it didn't work for me I mean I I
answer emails every single day I try
that it didn't work I'm like what about
it didn't work and you kind of like
deconstruct that and walk them through
that and more often than not it's their
own you know biases that aren't working
for them so I always want to make that
you know available for people and to
kind of
um uh you know remove like do my best to
kind
of put to the LIE like whatever notion
they have about what it is and it isn't
you know and a lot of people get hung up
on the god stuff and we all have our
baggage with religion and things that
have happened to us so you know I'm I'm
sympathetic to that but I think there's
ways around that and again I'm saying
this uh from the perspective not to
be critical in the least of what you're
doing I think what you're doing is super
powerful and it is providing this
amazing welcome that for the you know
Untold millions of people who have some
kind of issue ranging from very moderate
to somewhat concerning with respect to
their use of alcohol and you're able to
capture those people redress that
problem and produce Better Lives as a
result and I think that that is a worthy
mission for your life and I think to
heed the words of the doy Lama and to
take that to heart and put them into
action is is quite audible you know I
think it's a beautiful thing that you're
doing thank you yeah the the the one
thing in there is you know once you've
discovered um having an impact on people
and this links interestingly back to
ADHD and also emotions a lot of people
who from a young age have a very high
level of emotion we can call some of
those empaths have a high level of
emotion they then turn to alcohol and
drugs right because they struggle to
deal with those emotions but what
happens when you remove that from people
uh you remove the alcohol you remove the
the numbing is now you bring back that
emotion you talking about Live Wire
without any tools for coping with all of
those confusing emotions but they're
also highly empathic and what people
find is that you know what empathic
people usually feel like they need to
give back and they're in jobs or they're
in careers where they don't feel like
that and that was me um you know I
didn't feel like I was giving back at
all and so when I made that shift over
to a purposeful life of helping people
right that is another level of being
able to yeah it's an inoculation against
that I mean I know what it's like to be
in a career both when I was drinking and
when I was sober and not feel fulfilled
not feel purposeful and not feel like
what I was doing had any real extrinsic
meaning uh other than like getting a
paycheck every two weeks and when you're
in that place you want to numb out from
your life and those uncomfortable
emotions and you'll you know find
yourself overspending or thinking that
you're you know if you buy this thing
it's going to make you feel better and
now being on a trajectory where I I
really do feel connected to meaning and
purpose and service totally all of that
goes away like that that is something
that kind of Falls by the wayside
because you don't feel compelled by it
anymore it doesn't it doesn't lure you
because what you're doing is is
basically satisfying that craving in a
healthy way I'll give you an example a
guy I'm seeing tomorrow um he he was
scrolling in innocently through
Instagram stumbled across my one of our
ads and in it it says do you feel like
you've got more to give do you feel like
there's more out there for you and
you're just not quite achieving as much
as you want to achieve then I guarantee
you it's probably alcohol right that's
the conversation and he's looking at and
he's like well I've built 300 million
turnover businesses um so I don't feel
like I've not been successful but I do
feel like alcohol could be holding me
back right so that's where it came from
for him he clicks on jumps in has a
conversation with me and he says about
the program he's like you know I just
have a whiskey a day you know I come
home I have a whiskey and then at the
weekends it's you know a few more but
it's not a problem everyone's doing it
normally that's just what it is and
we're like okay well that's fine no
problem but we guarantee you that this
is holding you back in a significant way
so he's like okay if I come on this
program and it has an impact on me I'm
going to help you so he comes through
this thing and once again we help him
find some significant trauma he had no
idea about right and he's like I just
can't believe it now he comes to the end
Cole with um our coach my wonderful wife
she he is our lead coach and he says do
you know what I believe it's my life's
purpose to help you guys grow this
program and that is the element we're
sitting here saying is passively sitting
on the couch just maybe drinking a
little bit too much to profoundly life
changed when you start to address and
help people see that alcohol is not the
problem it's just the outcome it's the
result it's the result of some things
you're doing in your life and when you
make those shifts is life
transforming you don't have to tell me
man exact so many lives transformed as I
said earlier in in in in ways that would
just absolutely blow your mind people
traversing from
the bottom depths of insanity to Leading
productive lives of meaning like it is a
it's a remarkable thing and when you get
to participate in that um it changes it
changes you it changes who you are and
it changes your sense of possibility and
it and it also you know connects you to
the value of being in service of that of
that mission which clearly clearly you
are yeah yeah it's a beautiful one to be
on cut me open I am it's it's
unbelievable the the the the passion for
this subject matter like I said you know
this conversation might be the Catalyst
for somebody to make that change and you
know putting families back and things
like that so you know never stop having
this conversation um let's really ramp
it up now like this is the time like
let's let's really get this conversation
going out there because there are so
many people suffering the very the very
very piece of alcohol is suffering I
mean you drink any amount and you feel
like suffering the next day everybody is
suffering with hangovers at the weekends
so I think um yeah let's just keep
having the
conversation we never came back around
to the the letter of unrequited love to
to Sir Richard Branson Richie
Bri um yeah so well through all the
raising of cash and you know we now have
over 4,000 investors every single pitch
every single conversation I mentioned
about this letter to Branson and it
being my fuel and you know what we were
here to have an impact and as I kept
bringing out that message I had a
message one day um from a guy through um
Joe polish um who was who was in genius
Network and he messaged me and he said
I've just heard your story about Richard
Branson amazing um I'm going to neker
Island do you want to come with me and
I'm like yes I'm about to fulfill my
life's dream this is unbelievable I
can't believe it and he put me in touch
with the organizer and um the organizer
was like he'd just done a year
alcohol-free not through us but somebody
had mentioned to him about you know one
year no doing one year no no beer um and
so I spoke to him and he was all really
excited and he was like when you tell
Richard Branson this story he's going to
love it like you sit there FaceTime your
dad sitting next to Richard Branson like
this is full circle from those suicide
attempts to to um coming through so it
was all lined up to happen and I was
heading off to neker Island um and then
the pandemic happened um and the trip
got canceled um and 2 months later my
dad died and
um when my dad passed um you know I was
very very fortunate through this
organization um thankfully for the
business that I spent the last four
weeks with him um caring for him and he
was an incredible human and he he always
wanted me to believe that I could do
more that I could do something great in
the world
and so he was he was my greatest
champion so I'm very sad that I didn't
get to have that moment but um wine Ford
you know some more time a few months go
by and I heard that some people close to
Branson were doing our challenge through
various other people and I was like okay
we're getting closer um and then I heard
that somebody very close was doing um
the program and so this got exciting and
next minute again another 6 months year
goes by and I'm lying in bed one night
one of those sleepless nights you know
that happen when you run an
organization and I'm looking at my phone
and there is you know he's in miiaa
opening up the new hotel so I shot a
message to um the person I knew like are
you here yeah you should come up and
then they never responded and I was like
come up where so I thought you know
fortune favors the brave just turn up so
I headed up to there went to the hotel
couldn't find the person couldn't see
anything very busy camera crew around
people running around I said um I'm
going to meet somebody can I have a
coffee and they were like yeah sure just
go out onto the Terrace and I kid you
not as I walked through that Archway
into there I walked out onto the patio
and he could have been anywhere in that
moment like filming they were doing a
tennis thing Richard was standing in the
pull pit staring out at The View on his
own so I just walked up beside him and I
said amazing view and he was like it's
one of my favorite in the world I said
hey Rich
can I tell you a story and he said is it
funny I said no but I might cry um and
then I started to tell him the story um
about you know suicide and coming back
from that and the impact we were having
and getting tearful and he gave me a big
hug and um after telling him the story
of what we were trying to achieve you
know he said um well we won't have that
lunch but how about we have dinner
tonight um so yeah my wife and I we she
came up as well and we had dinner with
him and it was an amazing moment that
really taught me one thing and I think
that is that the most important factor
when you are trying to change something
like this we talked earlier about a
paradigm shift happening not in months
or weeks in decades right my vision now
is in in decades not and the most
important thing is one thing people talk
about consistency they talk about that
no water will break down anything any
Rock anything over time is persistence
it's just persistence and that's the
thing with this right I was thought it
was all going to happen very quickly I'm
nine years into this message I'm now
looking at the next couple of decades
just here saying this one thing that if
you are regularly drinking alcohol then
I guarantee you it is holding you back
and you have these two archangels in the
dolly llama and Sir Richard Branson on
each shoulder and then joa some here as
well and Rich shouting in your ear Rich
shouting in your ear these Champions who
are helping
us keep going and keep sharing the
message you know one thing and you may
resonate with this at the darkest
moments of running this business which
is the biggest challenge of my life at
the hardest times when you're almost
ready to switch the lights off when
there's nowhere to go anymore and it's
so hard and I'm cry crying on the phone
to my mom going what am I doing like why
am I doing this and she said when you
want to show up big in the world you're
going to have to push through a lot of
stuff so just everyone out there keep
persisting and especially with this
message just keep sharing the message
keep inspiring people to drink less keep
talking about your sobriety keep talking
about what you did to change it like
let's rise up let's all help each other
beautiful um the final thing before
we put a close to this um as we welcome
uh a new year it's 2024 by the time this
goes up yes um in consideration of that
and understanding and seeing you as this
change agent which you are um I wanted
to kind of close with thoughts that you
might want to share with the person
who's listening to this who's
entertaining the possibility of making
this change for maybe the first time
what are your thoughts on the nature of
change itself like how do you approach
the process of making that change what's
the best way to begin and more
importantly maybe what's the best way to
sustain it to follow through on that
process great
question so I think that it is small
baby steps is what is how we create
change over time time is making small
iterations um and so if you're going to
if you are currently in dry January and
you're taking a break from alcohol start
to make fundamental shifts in the areas
of your life you know things like who
you hang out with all the time because
if everyone you hang out with all the
time is saturated in booze guess what
you're going to go back to that um the
all the different things that we touched
in here like start making these
improvements in your life because the
alcohol coming is a product of how you
are living your life and just very
gently start taking those steps I would
say to anyone who has been here before
and taken a break and found it come back
I would
say please please stop going in search
of willpower stop going in search of
more I can do this I can do this on my
own and instead go in search of four
things accountability connection support
and education and they can come in all
sorts of ways they can come in 12ep they
can come in Reading sober books and um
alcohol-free um articles and listening
to podcasts like this so go in search of
the tools that will help you change um
and I think
lastly I'm just going to scratch that
itch
again there are two things people say to
me after they've changed their
relationship with alcohol number one I
had no idea the impact alcohol was
having on me until I changed my
relationship with it and number two
I wish I'd done it sooner MH so don't be
that guy or gal let's not wait let's
just get on thank you thank you Rich I
loved it um it's a beautiful Mission
you're on and I appreciate you coming
here and and and sharing with me I think
that uh many lives will be impacted by
what what you had to say today so thank
you and uh more power to you I'm at your
service if there's anything I can ever
do for you please reach out in the
meantime time everybody who's listening
or watching if you want to learn more
about Ru and his mission you can do that
easily by going to oneyear beer.com your
book the 28 day alcohol free challenge
boom nailed it that's it um you can buy
that anywhere Amazon wherever um
anywhere else you want to direct people
or anything coming up in January that
would be of interest to people that are
enjoying this yeah we we have all of our
challenges to help people who need a
self-help um course uh check out
complete control if you feel like you
need a little bit more support um and
you know we provide tons and tons of
free content um our our social media uh
o MB or one year no beer um our
community our huge Facebook groups and
things like that they're all part of the
challenge and we also have our own
podcast which you should come on Rich
yes the one the the onee no beer podcast
yes how long you been doing that oh
we're now well nowhere near your your
downloads but doing for a while though a
lot a lot of guest Over N years yeah
yeah some really really good really good
guests nine years exactly that's no
slouch yeah I don't think I don't think
it's nine years it can't be because you
started one year no beer in 2015 yes did
you start the podcast right away pretty
very close I think no probably two years
after gosh I'm my memory but yeah yeah
um I think uh yeah so it's it's six
seven years yeah cool really clearly not
good at timelines you listen to podcast
anyway man that was great thank you uh
come back and share some more with me
and uh let's get you outside so you can
enjoy this beautiful uh weather we got
here in Los Angeles although in mayorca
it's probably better but anyway you're
here for a bit you enjoy your time I I
just want to say Rich again you like
huge kudos to you you know a huge kudos
to you for having us on and sharing this
message I think this is the greatest
thing we can do is really share this
message to inspire people around this
one thing which you know is absolutely
going to happen over the next decade or
two um the the time is up for alcohol um
so thank you yeah absolutely well least
I can do at your service again thanks R
thank you cheers
peace
that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. Rich
roll.com if you'd like to support the
podcast the easiest and most impactful
thing you can do is to subscribe to the
show on Apple podcast on Spotify and on
YouTube and leave a review and or
comment supporting the sponsors who
support the show is also important and
appreciated and sharing the show or your
favorite episode with friends or on
social media is of course awesome and
very helpful and finally for podcast
updates special offers on books the meal
planner and other subjects please
subscribe to our newsletter which you
can find on the footer of any page at
Rich roll.com Today's show was produced
and engineered by Jason Cameo with
additional audio engineering by Kale
Curtis the video edition of the podcast
was created by Blake Curtis with
assistance by our creative director Dan
Drake portraits by Davy Greenberg
graphic and social media assets courtesy
of Daniel CIS thank you George wayy for
copywriting and website management and
of course our theme music was created by
Tyler Patt Trapper Patt and Harry mathys
appreciate the love love the support see
you back here soon peace
plant
[Music]
day